I know death he's got many faces I look
forward to seeing this one
[Music]
everything you did not you where you are
now where you belong
[Music]
they're coming
our enemy doesn't time
[Music]
doesn't stop
doesn't feel
[Music]
I promise to fight for the living
hey everybody its charlie we finally got
our Game of Thrones Season 8 trailer
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
buried in the backgrounds of a lot of
these shots so we'll break it down shot
by shot there's a new round of the book
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video so first things first we
start with the Aria voiceover talking
about the faceless men while she's
running through the castle so obviously
they're mixing a lot of shots the
voiceover is coming from her looking at
the dragon glass getting really excited
about the army of the Dead like I'm not
afraid I look forward to meeting deaths
face when it arrives talking about the
night King but the shot of her running
through the battlements is obviously
from the actual battle during episode 3
so for the most part I think all the
footage that we see is just up to
episode 3 the first half of the season
because they alternate between shots of
people arriving at Winterfell the golden
company arriving at King's Landing
Cersei meeting Euron and the leader of
the golden company in the actual battle
itself which is episode 3 and because
they've been hyping it up so much I
think they're just focusing most of the
trailer on that the tension before a lot
of the interpersonal politics that
happen in those first couple of episodes
the calm before the storm that I talked
about in my last teaser video into the
actual explosion of battle itself the
thing that's different about this
trailer than previous seasons is that
usually all the Game of Thrones trailers
contain footage from pretty much almost
the entire season up to the final
episode this season obviously they want
to hold back as much as possible
especially from those last couple of
episodes there's a shot of Davos walking
on the battlements probably before the
battle happens because it's still so
dark behind them this guy hasn't been
lit with red fire there's a shot of
Varys Gilly the women and children
hiding in the crypts at Winterfell
probably during the battle while it's
going on just because Varys looks so
concerned so they're actually using the
crypts a lot for a lot of different
reasons one for the obvious reason where
Jon Snow goes to talk so to speak to his
father that he thinks Ned Stark and see
his mother Lyanna Stark just a ponder
the weight of everything consider what
they have to do next the big task ahead
of them so I'll talk about those shots
too because there's a couple shots of
Jon Snow
in the crips with Daenerys but the Crips
themselves would be the safest place for
them to go during the battle there's a
shot of Euron bringing back the golden
company then you actually see the leader
of the golden company in his golden
armor with very blond Targaryen looking
hair remember that it's important
because the golden company was founded
by a bunch of black buyers Targaryen
bastards that lost the Blackfyre
rebellion and were exiled to the east
and if you didn't know what their motto
is it's our word is as good as gold
their claim to fame is is that not only
are they really good at their job they
also have never broken a contract with
anyone so you know what that means if
their word is as good as gold and their
Targaryen bastards and you have a
Targaryen queen in the north what a
surprise it would be then if they broke
their contract to serve Daenerys and
turn against Cersei there's a shot of
beric torment and heed from the Nights
Watch yeah that confirmed alive we all
knew that they were gonna be alive
entering what looks like could be the
crypts Winterfell or one of the doors at
Winterfell just because they're walking
down a flight of stairs if the only
places that you walk downward in
Winterfell if you're not up at the top
of the castle is when you're walking
down into the crypts so that's why I
think that it's the crypts there's also
a shot later in the trailer of Jon Snow
rushing with a bunch of Targaryen and
stark soldiers at that same door then
you get the voiceover of Brande talking
probably to Jon Snow while you get a
couple shots of the Dragons flying over
Winterfell and Sansa freaking out like
oh my god those are a couple of dragons
he says everything you did brought you
where you are now where you belong home
based on the context of what he says for
a minute I thought he could be talking
about Jamie but when he says the word
home I think he's talking to Jon Snow
because Jon is gonna be so torn about
his Targaryen heritage but Winterfell is
the home that he knows Ned Stark is the
father that he knew even if he's not his
biological father love the way they cut
in shots of King's Landing and Cersei
looking very pleased with herself while
he's giving that voice over to because
she's probably seeing you're on ships
move into the bay you see a little boy
in winter town just south of Winterfell
watching Daenerys his army marched
through this is just extra footage from
the scene of Arya that we got a little
while ago so just more context for
what's happening during that from
different viewpoints you get an up-close
wide shot of the unsullied Army with Jon
Snow and Daenerys marching behind them
like we all thought then you get your
shot of dinner
meeting John snow in the crypts at
Winterfell now you can't really tell
which statue he's at but I'm assuming
that in this one it's relatively early
and he's going to Ned Stark statue
because the weight of everything is so
extreme what they're trying to do save
the world from certain death and he's
trying to model himself his life is an
adult and a leader after Ned Stark so
even though Ned Stark died in the first
season he is so important to what's
happening this season there's gonna be
so many references to season 1 moments
particularly the pilot episode so what
happened in the pilot episode after
Robert Baratheon arrived at Winterfell
they had that funny moment in the
courtyard then immediately he went down
to the crypts to visit lianna's statue
so this is probably their version of
that where they go down and they visit
Ned Stark's statue you get a shot of the
forges you see Gendry who's probably
helping them forge weapons and armor
because the really cool Easter egg in
the background of some of these shots
later when you see the breastplate is
that it's the Targaryen sigil mixed with
the stark wolf sigil so you have combo
breastplates a few people told me that
they actually had a wrap party with
these combo sigils so HBO will probably
be selling combo merge with this sigil
later this year I don't know what date
it'll be available or anything like that
because obviously if they had shown this
earlier it would have been a big spoiler
but it makes sense because all these
people here aren't part of the unsullied
they're not Dothraki bloodrider x' and
those were Daenerys as only soldiers
when they arrived at Winterfell so
everybody that's wearing this combo
breastplate is probably a northerner you
get the voiceover from Jon Snow our
enemy doesn't tire doesn't stop doesn't
feel they give you a shot of grey worm
and myths and ayat they're still pushing
that ship pretty hard grey worm is
standing at the front of the army -
there's a lot of main characters at the
front of the infantry line when the army
of the Dead arrives they did confirmed
they're gonna kill a lot of main
characters during those first three
episodes particularly the big battle
episode during episode 3 you get a big
wide shot of the dragons flying over the
forests in the area around Winterfell
the corresponding shot in winter town of
Arya either looking up at Jon Snow or
looking up at the dragons and smiling
because she's excited now that he's back
there's a shot of Jon Snow and the
godswood at the heart tree this is a
very similar scene that you would see
Ned Stark he spent a lot of time in the
godswood during season one before
went down to King's Landing you get a
new shot of the Hound in the middle of
the battle you could see all that fire
behind him this will remind you of the
infamous Blackwater fight with all the
fire behind him where he had one of his
most famous quotes ever on the TV show
you see someone hacking away at White's
on top of the battlements at Winterfell
they're using their right hand so I'm
assuming it's not Jamie it could be the
Hound but then you do get a shot of
Jamie screaming something screaming
orders at someone but just remember that
Jamie uses his left hand to fight so if
you see someone swinging away with their
left hand is probably Jamie you get a
shot of Cersei inside a very empty iron
throne room meeting what looks like
you're on and the leader of the golden
company you see a shot of Cersei
drinking wine and it'll remind you
because of the way they cut this into
the trailer that is just like the
Blackwater episode where she was
hunkered down in maegor's holdfast with
Sansa and her ladies-in-waiting just
getting drunker and drunker that's where
all the more wine
memes came from was her sassing everyone
swinging her wine glass around because
she was pretty sure that they might wind
up dying that night the other really
important thing about this scene too is
that because this is probably from the
first three episodes Cersei is really
pregnant and guzzling wine Cersei style
and being pregnant do not mix she looks
like she's been crying a little bit
so this could be after she loses the
baby it's hard to tell Cersei seems like
someone who might be willing to drink a
little bit of wine while she's pregnant
but he never really can't tell with her
there's a shot of Jamie arriving at
Winterfell in the Great Hall just giving
the same speech I made a promise I
intend to keep it so this is probably in
the first episode sometime
you see someone sharpening their blade
it's hard to tell who it is
but then you see Jon Snow and those
soldiers marching at the same door that
Barrack was going into it could be the
crypts at Winterfell it could just be
one of the other entrances to the castle
then you get a shot of Jon Snow and
Daenerys outside way beyond the walls at
Winterfell walking up to drogon and
regal looking like they just finished
their lunch
it doesn't look human because the
skeletons and the spines here just seem
way too large so it could be some
animals but it reminds you of the scene
during season four where'd Rokon roasted
the Shepherd's son and you see this
charred remains on the ground there but
they seem pretty casual when they're
walking up to the Dragons so I'm
assuming that these are just a couple
animals and they were just getting
something to eat you get a different
shot of Sansa looking very severe on the
battlements this is probably when she
notices Daenerys is army marching in
through winter town before the draw
mehgan's fly overhead and freak her out
then you get a shot of Aria fighting on
the battlements with a dragon
glass-tipped spear there's a shot of
Daenerys looking like she just got some
really really heavy news inside
Winterfell possibly during episode 1
episode 2 maybe this is after they find
out Jon Snow is secretly a Targaryen and
she's just like oh Jesus I don't know
how to deal with this there's a shot of
Tyrion looking way way up either at the
dragons or Daenerys on one of the
dragons you get a different shot of
drogon in the middle of the night
possibly during the battle opening up in
flame you get a slow pan to the front of
the army with Brienne and Podrick and
Jorah probably all the other big main
characters that are capable of fighting
on the ground you also reminded about
the combo breastplate some of the
northerners here of the stark sigil and
the Targaryens digital together then the
camera pans to the left and you see the
undead horse's hoof march in that's not
necessarily the night king because
remember during the season 7 finale when
the army of the Dead marched up to the
wall the night king actually flew in on
Viserion while he was destroying the
wall there was just a regular white
Walker that was leading the army on
horseback so it's probably that same
white Walker but let me know in the
comments what's your favorite part of
the trailer and if there's any Easter
eggs that you saw that I didn't mention
in the video and all these shots just
write them below in the comments what'll
happen is I'll do a follow-up video for
this tomorrow for some of the bigger
stuff leave your requests in the
comments below
and I'll name a giveaway winner when I
post that while you wait for everything
click here for my teaser video I talked
a little bit about what they've said
about that big battle and how it plays
out and what's gonna be going on and
click here for all my other Game of
Thrones season 8 trailer and promo
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you